welcome back to peers working on
Saturday the 87th day of 2023 but
America's experience is 129th mass
shooting of the year three children aged
just nine and three adults were killed
at a school in Nashville Tennessee a
former student Audrey Hale a biological
woman identify as a transgender or did
before she was killed and apparently
used his male pronouns but frankly who
cares about the pronouns
well certainly by comparison to the
appalling coward is shown by police at
the avalde mass shooting where you may
remember uh 20 were killed the police
there deserve full uh credit for the
courage that they showed in taking down
that shoot joining me now is Ashby
Beasley who herself survived a mass
shooting in Illinois only last year
along with Fox news commentator and Alki
Coast Tommy lahren who lives just
minutes away from the school the scene
of this lady shooting well welcome to
both of you
um I want to start with you Ashby if I
may now you and your 60 year old son
were present at a shooting in Highland
Park Illinois last summer where seven
people were killed and 48 injured and
then by an extraordinary coincidence
having campaigns since then for gun law
reforms you happen to be on a family
vacation right in Nashville when this
latest shooting happened and you went
down to the scene and you spoke
incredibly movingly to the media with us
take a look at this
aren't you guys tired of covering this
aren't you guys tired of being here and
having to cover all of these mass
shootings I'm from Highland Park
Illinois my son and I survived a mass
shooting over the summer I am in
Tennessee on a family vacation with my
son visiting my sister-in-law I have
been lobbying in DC since we survived a
mass shooting in July I have met with
over 130 lawmakers how is this still
happening how are our children still
dying and why are we failing them
well they're good questions uh Ashby
thank you very much indeed for joining
me what motivated you to go there and
and say such a passionate thing there to
the media
you know only in America can someone
like me who survived a mass shooting
last year with my six-year-old son go to
a rally in DC that is being put on by
the survivors of another mass shooting
Newtown Connecticut
and then stopped by to visit my
sister-in-law in Nashville and meet up
with a friend whose son was killed in a
mass shooting in a Waffle House in
Antioch Tennessee who I met in DC
lobbying and only on the day when we
plan to have lunch could another mass
shooting happen down the street from
that friend's you know Sun School a son
who was at the mass shooting that killed
his brother only in America can you find
yourself in that kind of a situation I
mean just Harry you know when she called
well just sorry just to drop it just to
hear what you've just said I've got to
say sitting here in London that kind of
sentence is just extraordinary to people
here it's not to me because I've lived
and worked in America for a long time
but it's just the relentlessness of
these shooties and in particular the
relentlessness of school shootings there
have been I think over 80 school
shootings in America this year alone I
mean we had a appalling one in the UK in
dunblane Scotland in 1996 and we
irrevocably changed a lot of our gun
laws and we didn't have the same amount
of guns in circulation just to be clear
there's a different problem here
um this was the front page of a Daily
Mirror at the time I was the editor I
helped drive a campaign to make things
safer and we've not had a school
shooting since 1996. America's had over
80 this year what do you think Ashby is
the answer to this because Congress
which would change the rules change the
laws seems completely locked on this
completely gridlocked almost like
nothing can be done
well I'm glad that you said 1996 because
since 1999 children in American schools
have experienced gun violence over 350
000 children have experienced gun
violence in schools since 1999. so you
change your laws in 96 we haven't
changed our laws since then and the toll
is just growing our government needs to
step in our lawmakers need to step in
and they need to pass gun safety
legislation the access to weapons of war
that acts the easy access to guns is
what's killing us it's what's killing
our children and there is no other
answer than passing gun safety
legislation ninety percent of American
citizens support background checks
Universal background checks let's do it
let's get it done right let's bring in
Tommy here look Tommy you and I have
discussed guns I mean it seems like
forever this is a groundhog day debate
I'm not going to sit here as a Brit
until Americans how to lead their lives
I tried that once it didn't go down very
well so let's try a different tactic
here which is I think the key phrase
which I heard there from Ashby was
rather than using gun control which is
complete anathema to many Americans
particularly in a British accent because
you as you rightly point out drove us
out with guns so you don't want to hear
it from us I get it I get all that
but she mentioned gun safety
what can be done to make things safer
because things far from getting safer in
America all what's happening is the
number of guns in circulation are
exponentially increasing well over 400
million now and so the number of
shootings are increasing mass shooting
school shootings everything's increasing
you as an American citizen cannot be
happy about that surely what do we do
about it
well I will tell you this I want to talk
about the mental health aspect of this
in a moment but first I want to address
the gun rights and the gun safety debate
in question so here in the United States
we use guns to protect everything that
we hold near and dear to protect our
politicians our celebrities our red
carpets our jewelry stores you name it
everything that we deem important we put
people with firearms that are trained to
use those Firearms to protect those
entities and those individuals we do not
protect our schools like we should and
if you look into this Shooter's
background you look into their Manifesto
they had a map of this school because
what we use to protect our schools is a
little sign that says gun-free zone so
when you're looking at soft targets if
you are a psychopath a freak a monster
you look for places where you can go and
cause Carnage and damage where nobody
will be able to stop you now thank God
for our Nashville officers that
responded so quickly and were able to
neutralize that monster and that threat
but had we had somebody outside of that
school that was trained with a firearm
they could have neutralized that yeah
we know what happened at uvaldo there
were hundreds of good guys with guns and
none of them had the guts to go and
think about it and 20 kids got killed so
it's not a given that actually if you
have a load of people who are good
people with guns in these schools it
makes any difference we saw what
happened on the video here about what
this person did but on a wider point I I
tweeted today for example look rather
than get into the same old debates what
about uh regulating guns in America as
in the same way you regulate cars and I
got an unbelievable amount of abuse
immediately just endless abuse as if I
didn't know what I was talking about but
when I actually then posted a piece by
Nick Kristoff who was at the New York
Times at the time and I explained what I
meant and I'm just going to pre-see what
the piece was a brilliant piece it was a
few years ago but he said if we had the
same Auto fatality rate today that we
had in 1921 by my calculations we'd have
we'd have 715 000 Americans dying
annually in vehicle accidents instead
we've reduced that fatality rate by 95
percent not by confiscating cars or
taking them away but by regulating them
and their drivers more sensibly and then
he goes into all the things that have
happened in that period right they
talked about requiring driver licenses
uh putting speed limits registering
Vehicles all of that was originally met
with ridicule when authorities in New
York City saw in 1899 to ban Horseless
carriages in the Parks the idea was
lambasted as devoid of Merit and
impossible to maintain by the New York
Times yeah over time as more and more
people were being killed by cars they
brought in more and more regulation by
the 1920s a lot of this stuff like car
registration license requirements other
safety measures and then over time seat
belts airbags padded dashboards better
bumpers rules about drunken drivers
graduated licensing the young people
improved Road engineering blah blah blah
the upshot of all that was that there's
now just over one car fatality per 100
million miles driven and so it was a
very well argued point and at the center
of it was not a claim which I know goes
down very badly with gun owners in
America that you want to ban guns or
grab guns I'm always going to gun
Grabber I don't want your guns trust me
um but about making it as safe as Cards
doing what happened to cars why not just
do that and see what happens
well here's the thing somebody that's
going to go into a school and murder
children is not like your average driver
who needs to obey a speed limit or wear
a seat belt somebody that's going to go
in to murder students clearly does not
care about laws in general so what does
making law-abiding citizens making it
harder for us to have firearms what does
that do to stop a monster a psychopath a
freak now I understand your argument
here so we need gun safety we need
people to be trained how to use Firearms
to respect firearms and change the gun
culture in this country I'll also say in
the last 30 years gun ownership in the
United States really has not changed
much what has our mental health
situation and now thanks to the radical
lgbtq movement in this country we are
exploiting mental illness especially in
young people so when you look at this
particular shooter you look at their
background you look at the mental health
counseling and services they were
receiving probably gender affirmation
because that's the new that's the new
status quo now instead of saying this
person has a real mental illness that
needs to be addressed in an individual
basis we clean out Cloud everything
under the guise of gender affirmation
and tolerance the mental health aspect
is very important okay we got a lot of
discussion about gun safety okay to
address mental health and that's being
glossed on I couldn't agree more with
you about mental health all I would
point out is we have exactly the same
mental health problems in this country
and in many European countries and
because we don't have the availability
of guns we don't have 80 000 people a
year dying from Guns uh we had I think
one last year so that's what I would say
in return to that I want to come back to
to Ashby funding for this
the the local Congressman answer
something that she said yes sure can I
ask her something that she said
um you know statistically we know that
mass Shooters 77 of mass Shooters get
their guns legally that means that they
don't have a criminal record that means
that they're not doing the things wrong
they're not on some sort of list but I
was going to make the point get their
guns legally yeah I was going to make
the point that this particular shooter
was a woman transgender I just I'm not
interested in that aspect of the story
other than to say that she acquired
seven guns legally from five different
stalls right to which my and apparently
was at the same time receiving medical
treatment from a doctor for being
emotionally disturbed now to anyone with
half a brain this seems like an utterly
lethal cocktail but nothing in the
system stopped her I I'm interested also
Ash being in this this is Congressman
Andy ogles who is the congressman
responsible for that District so he's a
U.S lawmaker and in Christmas 2021 he
tweeted this Christmas card to the World
on his Twitter account let's take a look
at this that's him with his family all
clutching guns including young children
Merry Christmas from the Ogle's family
he wrote the atmosphere of firearms
anywhere and everywhere restrains evil
interference they deserve a place of
honor with all that's good
uh as some people have pointed out
that doesn't seem a particularly
responsible or appropriate thing for a
U.S congressman to be doing and now we
see perhaps in a disturbed mind what
that kind of mindset can do
yes and and if if I'm being honest you
know I look at a picture like that and
the glorifications of weapon the
glorification of weapons of war because
the AR-15 was designed for combat in the
1950s it is a gun that shoots smooth
it's it's an easy shot I shot one
recently
um you can put your your eye on the
barrel when you're firing an AR-15 and
you will not lose your eye it is
designed for ease for killing when I see
a gun like that in a picture like that
what I think of is I think of Mexican
cartels and how at Mexican cartels are
arming themselves with our guns they're
arming themselves with our guns over two
hundred thousand weapons are being
trafficked into Mexico every single year
Republicans like this Republican in this
picture is complaining about the
fentanyl crisis on a daily best basis
but all our assault weapons are
enforcing the funds I think none of our
lawmakers are doing anything yeah I
think the truth is they're both hugely
uh important issues in America they both
have huge toll on life I just think it's
completely inappropriate for a cousin be
putting Christmas cards out with his
kids all clutching rifles like that I'm
not sure what message he's trying to
send and I'm not saying he's responsible
for flying guns yeah
um look Tommy uh and Ashley thank you
very much I mean Tommy you and I we've
discussed this a lot I just hate the
Groundhog Day aspect I love America I
love Americans I respect the Second
Amendment I understand you can't take
all the guns away there are too many of
them this can't go on you can't just
wake up every few weeks and have another
school being shot up by people in
combats with with all these guns
something has to happen something has to
change and the thing I find most
frustrating and dispiriting about it is
Americans are the most can-do people in
the world
they get stuff done and yet on this this
total paralysis and when we did the
campaign in in the UK after dunblane
there was no partisanship or political
difference of opinion it was never
political I never really understood how
it's got that way in America here left
and right came together and when the
lives of kids come above everything and
I think until that is the starting point
I don't think anything happens in
America but look I appreciate we all
have different views on this I also
appreciate I'm not American so I
appreciate you both joining me and thank
you both very much